how about that [ __ ] idiotic picture
with what's that guy's name who's the
balls [ __ ] fell out of his pants when
he was rocking Lenny Kravitz Lenny
Kravitz do it
how about Lenny Kravitz in that idiotic
scarf he wears in that picture hey it's
too big bye hey man you could wrap up
your whole goddamn family in it bye what
are you in the [ __ ] he looks like
he's in the comfy matrix he looks like
the [ __ ] he looks like he's in the
[ __ ] comfy matrix what would you like
the little scarf or the big scarf how
comfortable do you want to be Lenny
Kravitz would you like a scarf dude and
then there's that Photoshop picture
where they made it [ __ ] way bigger
[ __ ] him dude straight up hey Lenny
Kravitz you scarce to bake pie in the
comfy matrix would you like the red pill
or the blue pill the red pill gives you
a regular-sized scarf you'll be nice and
warm you'll be warm in LA and probably
even in New York but in the tundra
you'll freeze or you can take the blue
pill the blue pill gives you a larger
scarf and even in the tundra you'll be
very warm and Lenny Kravitz was like
I'll take the blue pill be around well
here you go and then he did it and then
[ __ ] rocked out spread his legs to
wide with his skinny jeans and his balls
fell out hey Lenny Kravitz your boss
fell out while you were rocking out you
know welcome to mm whatever it was you
know never happen Elvis and he [ __ ]
did lots of open leg [ __ ] it happened to
me once once I was on stage at the Jon
Lovitz comedy club it was a makeshift
comedy club that was in San Diego for a
little bit and of course it went out of
business but hey Jon level Jon Lovitz
comedy club in San Diego course it's
going out of business anyway
had some [ __ ] speakers up on
tri-powered SIA so that he's a nice guy
but dude right and so so I [ __ ] did
the [ __ ] I did a splits on stage what
not a splits I [ __ ] did a [ __ ]
dance like I do and my [ __ ] pants
straight up opened up and thank God I
had [ __ ] underwear on because my
balls what a little roof fell into
the first and second row of the audience
because they're so goddamn big dude my
balls are so big dude it's crazy man
they would I would a little that he
killed they would they would have died
the people in the front row would have
died cuz my balls would have suffocated
him but what's the song that he does the
[ __ ] just wanna [ __ ] get away just saw
on a flower yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] fly
away what do you what dude you know what
huh what he literally wrote that song
woke up in the morning was just like he
hung in him write a [ __ ] song that you
[ __ ] [ __ ] he said that to whoever was
next to him to the chick some [ __ ]
super hot model and he had a scarf on
when he woke up and he was like hey I'm
Lenny Kravitz dude get out of my house
yo I'm gonna write a [ __ ] song today
[ __ ] and she [ __ ] left and he was
just like wrote the song with only a
shirt on and a big-ass scarf and the
whole time he was thinking about like I
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that's what he was
thinking you know dude Lenny Kravitz is
a is a real person and how about when
Lenny Kravitz did the target commercial
and everybody was like he sold out oh
shut the [ __ ] up dude let me tell you
something man if I had 75 number-one hit
singles you better goddamn believe I'm
doing commercials for Target Starbucks
McDonald's Apple [ __ ] Banana Republic
Lexus all the companies dude all the
companies and I'm raking in I'm raking
in the [ __ ] money I'm [ __ ] raking
in the money Kohl's commercial Lenny
Kravitz did a Kohl's commercial what are
they
sell pots and pans [ __ ] this call sell
everything right you can get anything at
Kohl's you can literally buy an elf from
Kohl's
you can go into cause me like we're your
elves and they'd be like Aisle seven
sorry what's up hey how's that Darwin
did you need one how tall are you
I'm three feet give anyone smaller yeah
just go down go further down that red
and then way down that way they're like
oh how tall are you
I'm free okay I'll take two of you cool
let's go Tim okay Travis and then your
fault OOP OOP got two trolls or what I
say else got two elves cool and I'll get
some towels too and some pots and pans
chocolate cones come on get in the car
you [ __ ] elves